how are you doing today sir doing good
how are you
uh i'm gonna say i don't appreciate you
making me cry last night so
that's how i'm gonna start i'm gonna say
fu on that okay
being being completely serious you did
such an awesome job in this
um
playing evan has been such a big part of
your life for the last few years i am
curious what was it like like the last
day on set knowing that this might be
the last time you're playing this role
honestly it was it was a relief i mean i
i
have loved the experience and i feel
really grateful that i got to be the one
to kind of finish the job and finish the
story and finish that journey
and this gave me such an incredible
opportunity to have closure and to
really say goodbye to each piece of
material one at a time as we shot each
sequence in each song and really give it
my last piece
so finally when we reach the end i i
just felt really ready i felt like i had
done everything i could do i had
immortalized everything i could think of
to immortalize and uh i had lived the
character in every way that you can i
realized it on stage and then got to
fully bring him into like a human
life on on screen and so
i just felt um
ready to go i felt i felt the transition
was welcome and i i felt i'm ready to
say goodbye
i couldn't believe the way you were able
to sing while also crying i don't know
how you actually did that and i'm as i
was watching you do this i'm like how
the f is he singing through these tears
so please can you tell me how do you
sing when you're crying
there's a certain you know
aspect of it that's somewhat ineffable
and sort of just you know happens when i
try to live the emotional truth and then
also perform musically i think i had the
privilege of getting to do it for so
long on stage where i really got to
understand the mess the muscle kind of
mechanics of how to make that happen and
you know not to be graphic about it but
it's about handling mucus and swallowing
and you know tears and you know how to
make sound resonate through that
but the weird you know thing about it
which i actually spoke to barbara
streisand about when she came backstage
because she is kind of fascinated too by
this crying and singing she's another
like master at emotional performance
while singing um this idea that actually
when you cry and you again to be graphic
when you empty out these passages like
in your in your nose and in your sinuses
you're actually creating lots of space
to resonate and make sound so weirdly
crying is actually not the worst time to
sing there's kind of good uh resonating
space to make to make healthy sounds
so that's sort of like the technical
aspect of it and then uh
performance-wise i think it's about the
balance of you know
delivering these beautiful pascal paul
songs to the best of my ability and
making sure that the melodies and the
musicality are present and that the song
is being heard in its entirety but also
not sacrificing that for
or or rather not sacrificing the the
emotion and the raw kind of authenticity
of the what's being communicated by the
song in favor of making it uh sort of
pretty or or pristine um and sort of
finding the the way that those can
interact one of the things about being
bringing this to movie screens is that
you're able to do things you can't do on
the stage for you what are some of your
favorite things that the movie is able
to portray reveal showcase that you
couldn't do on the stage
that's a great question i think in a
general sense the intimacy of evan's
internal life that you get on on film
and and really getting fully inside his
mind and inside his eyes and knowing
what he's feeling in any given moment or
the decisions he's making or feeling
like you actually are really inside his
head i think it's this very special
ability that film has to do that that's
just not possible in a giant theater um
so that i really loved um and then in
terms of the content you know i don't
want to give away for people that
haven't seen the film yet but there is a
whole kind of third act that doesn't
really exist in the musical once you
know evan's lie has come to light uh the
ways in which he's able to repent and
redeem himself and evolve and heal
in real time and we get to actually see
those things happen in a way that we
don't in the musical uh was a really
cathartic thing i think for me to see
and i think that a lot of people will
feel that way too
um i i agree the third act in the film
steven did such a great job with this i
agreed you know um i gotta go i'm just
gonna say again congrats uh you did such
a great job i hope it's a huge hit thank
you i so appreciate it cool thank you